successo effetti sonori vocali sempre
bella tutti ragazzi benvenute questo
video sono felice oggi siamo su un gioco
siamo su suo gioco zio a c'è un cane ben
fantastico supercane magiche 0 the
legend of the cane cane premi una roba
va bene
volevo ringraziare sio che con i quali
mi sento perché un bravo ragazzo ceo ha
sviluppato insieme allo studio ivo in
questo gioco da una vita e mezza avevo
giocato alla demo secoli fa oggi
giochiamo gioco ufficiale è sì o ci sono
i problemi
giochiamo senza joyce i premi una roba
che non sia un joystick aggiungiamo
nella prossimo menu nelle prossime dei
tre premi una loro kay questo genere a
salvataggi automatici quando vedi questa
icona animata da parte dello schermo
ovvero allora bollire le patate per un
secolo ragaglini ci potrei fare una
serie su questo gioco la meraviglia c'è
la modalità mega difficile che il gioco
ti prenderà letteralmente a pesci in
faccia però facciamo quella sfida
normale che almeno va bene modalità
storia partiamo ragazzi non ancora mai
giorgetti non ho mai giocato a verso un
ufficiale quindi sono veramente curioso
sono cose ma ci sono le classi cosa
fornaio a tanta vita e poco ego poco
lancio poi c'è l'idraulico il mago
l'influenza anna cosa non ha nessuna
abilità passiva a è a un punto a media
un po tutto quindi va bene usiamo
influenza che avrei scelto a prescindere
va bene tanto tempo fa nella lontana
terra conosciuta come molise viveva
giorgio un commercialista di bergamo ma
george non c'entro nulla con la sua
storia wow
la nostra storia mi doveva il magico
mondo di uo poi tempo fa circa e l'altro
giorno nella casa di mare del mago mago
torta un mago molto potente simpatico
sopra a fare tante magie per esempio
faceva apparire fate le più lente le
cose a volte faceva aprire un giorno
mentre stava mangiando un insalata di
torta starnuti cade al suolo e morì
il suo cani non è questo il modo in cui
dico a era lì vicino quando accade dalla
tristezza per qualche motivo diventa un
cane magico da quel momento ogni volta
che abbaia succedono cose molto strane
per esempio lucano laser e congelate
improvvisamente giovedì scorso e sono
caduti molti dolci dal cielo che hanno
spaccato tutto è in atto una vera e
propria tempesta di meteoriti di magia
canina chi potrà mai fermare il cane
magico anna cosa influencer eccomi come
sono finita qui cos'è questo posto
sembra un cratere forse sono un aliena
caduta sulla terra
allora sono fortissima wow cadere dallo
spazio e neanche un graffio c'è la
polizia ma che brutta ma chi sono chi
sei tu io sono un aliena ma è
impossibile
noi alieni abbiamo meno bulbi oculari a
perché sono loro gli alieni a vuoi
sapere il mio nome
se non ti dispiace mi chiamo poi non
ricordo nemmeno come mi chiamo meglio
inventarsi il nome al momento non vorrei
fare è aspettare questo gentil signora
jean robert box l'ho fatto con le cose
pre fatte del gioco va bene mi chiamo
john roberts box
ciao già rover box mi chiamo robot
crociaro bocchio perché volevi sapere
mio nome è giusto devo arrestarti per
formazioni di crateri e un consentiva
beh non fa una piega ma non l'ho fatto
apposta
capisco se in arresto lo stesso
uffa sono jean robert bob se mi hanno
arrestato che partenza incredibile
grazie ceo premi b per premere bis non
sa se vuoi premere a premi altrimenti
premi b
non so come ringraziarti sono in
prigione devo fuggire ma che bello pa pa
pa pa pa pa click tipo somiglia un po a
interagisci con le leve oggetti persone
usando a sembra un po la roba di prison
escape the prison no è quello che si
deve scappare la prigione che ho fatto
con pietro c'è un nokia di 5.300 quello
lì tremila nokia ragazzi il suo
indistruttibile detenuto e potresti
farmi favore di distruggere quei nodi di
alimentazione tengono chiudano la porta
ho promesso a mamma dismettere gli se un
teppista e ora non posso più ma rompere
le cose lanciando oggetti in giro va
bene lo faccio io che non ho promesso
niente a mia mamma partiva lanciarli dei
sassi che l'ho saputo dei soldi li
lancio dei soldi sono le loup e figo se
devo fare qua a devos casa a no devo
prendere devo appoggiare così nei posti
giusti come ha fatto quando ceo ha
dichiarato di volere kg aver preso parte
a questo progetto io vi do ma solo visto
otto milioni di volte la sua memoria con
la direzione artistica di sio e ceo fa
la musica e le cose mutande di tutto
dalla mutanda posso equipaggiarli alle
mutande togliti vogliamo tanda io avevo
già equipaggiata la mutanda
lo seguivo già perché l'ho cambiata
prima non c'è adesso sono nudo mutanda
del nonno calda confortevole protegge
completamente la parte inferiore del tuo
bulls o perfetto perché c'è ok non so
che cosa mi sembra sta roba un mio dio
ce l'ho fatta
no sono pirla nè man mango in super
mario faccio stiefel saltando da una
piattaforma all'altra ei poliziotti
aspetta premi le armi chi so proprio ad
entrare la prossima stanza una di quelle
sane persone verdura che abbiamo
arrestato a minestroni a sta attaccando
chiunque con la pa della miche l'occhio
è andato lì da solo lascia stare mi che
l'occhio veniamo lì noi la madonna sono
grossissimi spiega devo lanciare come si
lancia la spada ma non posso lanciare la
spalla va bene picchio
ho vinto di chianche tete usciti o che
bello diario di questa giornata perfetta
o se anche aperta la mappa in basso a
destra o gli aiuto solo piedi sono piedi
ma dove siamo noi siamo sulla terra
quindi ora la mela la prendo 2000 cooper
o la vita perfetto capito come si gioca
ragazzi siamo adesso andiamo a mille
basta sti piedi che rottura a posso
lanciare anche i nemici piedi contro le
cose a questa cosa mi mancava
li posso lanciare la gente va bene
lanciamo la gente ho trovato un
detersivo cuce un albero salve albero
saggio alla buon ora cominciano a
spazientirsi non perdiamo altro tempo in
guardia cosa questo cioè dovevo
picchiare l'albero un boss c boss albero
mamma mia
saliva ma come c'è un boss albero che è
stranissimo aiuto
mamma mia ragazzi può essere molto più
difficili quello che si pensa però ci
sono le angurie posso mangiare le
angurie per recuperare vita occhio le
foglie
l'hack è male aia malissimo ragazzi c'è
molta più sfida di quello che sembra in
realtà il suo gioco
ve lo assicuro supercane magiche ma
vedendo il cane ancora non l'ho visto io
ha evocato dei minion sono aiac e mare
beh mi sono scarsissimo o la bomba è
levato un sacco
questo lo magno bagnatelo effetto questo
non so cos'è me lo mangio provo
va bene questo pure vai così picchia
l'albero picchia lo quanta vita già sto
qua ci vuole una vita avevano fuori
sembra una cavolata ma non lo è ragazzo
vive uno scarso cioè veramente un è per
niente semplice sapienza cioè non dico
che è dark souls blog e morì quanto
tempo che male che ti salta in mente
falla finita capisco che sia lunedì ma
veri e di darsi una calmata non battere
la fiacca preparati a ricevere mio corpo
segreti hai detto lunedì si è sicura
pensò fosse settembre
sono sicura prima ho visto un canguro
ave certo quindi non se gli insegnanti
di lotta senza esclusione di colpi con
cui avevo appuntamento
eppure sei molto forte e chi se mi
ricordo la misura svegliata in un
carattere stamattina un cratere è
interessante misterioso pure sei
fortunata ragazza si dà il caso che io
sia l'albero saggio wow quindi sai dirmi
chi sono no ma andiamo a non fare gola
faccia sedia natura di un cratere si è
certamente una cometa compli fundament
azioni l'albero saggio che è rivelato
che sia una cometa premici non naviga
fino a schermata e credendo che mai deve
andare ma non posso battere lo stesso
albero ma adesso non posso battere più
mannaia una volta che dopo quasi battuto
tomas basta hai rotto
ok questo mangiamo no la bomba lo fa già
il più grande è mio nemico in realtà
sono io stesso ma questo l'ho sempre
detto società morire da solo non hai
visto niente tuo albero saggio perché
quello che ho fatto non era per niente
saggio lega o ragazzi non dare nel mondo
dei cavalli così devo fare o un giorno
mondo dei cavalli che c'erano prigione
idv off
qui vengono portati tutti i teppisti
vabbè via pop tarts a chi dice già i
nomi degli altri posti non è spero non
te li dice però sono tanti fondata da
hagrid grifondoro da agrifondo né
nell'anno 7 del ciclo settore dicessimo
da un po di anni a destra le 20 più
eccentriche dv delle arti della cane man
sia e della caramello genesi da date vi
prego game of the year che prendo la
lanterna che sicuramente può servirmi ti
può vedere note di viaggio jt biscotto
ho deciso di tenere un diario di
strappare delle pagine di seminari giro
perché sono scemo
mi domando dove abbiano spostato
all'archivio con i libri sulle crostate
beh non lo so tutto questo buio non si
vede nulla è meglio che il partito non è
questa e lanterna
bene cos'è questo contratto nomino di
marzapane oh mio dio nemici aiuto lo
picchiava vecchio l'arma quindi li
chiudi sono scarsini meno ma le note di
viaggio gt biscotto minuto 6 penso che
lanciano in giro nelle pagine di diario
dio la natura e la raccolta
differenziata
mi sa che devo prendere quello aspetta
che io lancio di tenete conto ecco
perfetto mi sa che devo prendere questa
roba e piazzando da qualche parte che
però non so dove ragazzi se riuscite a
portare la ciambella dalla parte opposta
e ho aperto un passato mi stanno
seguendo in 26 di come sono morto forse
ce la faccio ho letto
siamo riusciti andare avanti devo
riuscire a vedere se riesco a sbloccare
a battere il boss eventuale ci sarà qua
per immagini sia non c è mosso scherzavo
concludo qua il primo episodio di
supercane magik 0 è stato veramente alla
scoperta cioè come è come andare a
scuola non si capisce niente però è che
bello che bello
bravi vi sia piaciuto come al solito si
capisce dell'argomento mi piace e vi
lascio anche link di supercane magik 0
in descrizione spero di non dimenticar
melo se me lo dimentico non lo vedrete
però spero io sono ricordato io
ringrazio sia per questa direzione
artistica incredibile e lo studio i ball
per aver fatto questo giorno assurdo
fatemi sapere se avete continuo io l'ho
continuo
iscrivetevi al canale e mettete la
campanella perché vi arrivano le
notifiche ciao
[Musica]